c'est ne décolère pas les règles
sanitaires imposées par l'exécutif ne
passe toujours pas d'autant plus que le
gouvernement veut transformer le passé
notamment parce vaccinale s'ajoutent à
cela des récents propose sur les
non-vaccinés plutôt au fleury du
président qu'il dit pleinement assumée
de quoi peut être donner un nouveau
souffle à la mobilisation de ce samedi
plusieurs rassemblements à travers toute
la france rien qu'à paris iv dont celui
sur appel de florian philippot suivi par
notre reporter guillaume arrosé demande
qu'on le retrouve tout de suite
bonjour guillemin lors la manifestation
est elle partie
alors la manifestation à meyrannes elle
est même arrivé à parce qu'en fait des
manifestants sont partis il ya environ
une heure depuis la place du palais
royal et le cortège et
dirigés au pas de course à il faut bien
le dire je pense notamment du fait du
mauvais temps vers cette place vauban
actuellement des milliers de personnes
qui ont répondu à l'appel de florian
giraud à l'appel de la d6 les contres ne
pas vacciner je vous le répète encore
une fois malgré le mauvais temps et qui
seront arrivés sur cette place le
profond où ils règnent depuis longtemps
derrière à une ambiance musicale
suffisait pas
comment ce musical varier les genres
particulièrement motivés à se faire
entendre
silencieux et donc ou datant d'une
minute à l'autre la prise de parole de
deux failles ans filippo targuer main on
le sait c'est pas la première fois que
les patriotes défilent contre la
politique sanitaire du gouvernement
mais ce qu'on peut dire que cette fois
ci c'est plutôt symbolique
et oui tout à fait admirable faut dire
que l'actualité de cette semaine était
très chargé il y avait d'abord et bien
tout simplement le pass vaccinale en
lui-même qui a été adopté par
l'assemblée nationale ce jeudi au terme
de trois jours de débats mouvementés
houleux et qui doit entrer en vigueur au
15 janvier prochain en théorie après
avoir été examinée après que le projet
examiné par le sénat et puis il y a bien
entendu vous l'avez dit ces propos cette
phrase d'emmanuel macron 1.0 d'une
interview donnée un journal le parisien
mardi je cite le président de la
république les non-vaccinés j'ai très
envie de les emmerder des propos qui ont
choqué toute une partie de la population
au delà même des principaux concernés et
puis il vient bien que ces débats qu'on
a honte en langue qu'on a pu lire dans
la presse au cours de ces derniers jours
de ces dernières semaines comme par
exemple la question ça va les prendre en
charge les soins des personnes non
vaccinées ou même si ces personnes
vaccinées de vêtements à guise en soin
d'eux
animation par les opposants à la
vaccination tout maintenu ce projet on
passe de vaccinale ont eu du grain à
moudre c'est d'ailleurs ce même s'ils
sont fichés qui explique l'ampleur de
cette mobilisation aujourd'hui
merci un gay main pour toutes ces
précisions et